[Music]
having some wild little ones running
around can definitely be rewarding but
it could also be exhausting at times we
have a list of the best parenting hacks
to make your life easier and your
child's life safer stay tuned to see the
things you can create with toilet paper
new around the things give us a like and
hit the subscribe button for more great
videos like this now on 220 genius
parenting hacks that may just save you
more than your time and money
DIY play area it always seems like when
kids get to playing that their toys have
exploded everywhere and of course we
wonder how little humans seem to have a
knack for making a mess but it isn't
their fault they're adventurous so how
can you help them see where they're
spreading out into areas where people
may trip or step on toys I do it
yourself play area use tape that is made
for painting laws and tape off an
appropriate area where they normally
play make it into a game by having them
only play inside the tape by explaining
to them it's for their safety and others
they'll learn whether spaces Ziploc
vaycay pack zip locks are good for just
about anything food related but we've
got a new way for you to put your trusty
zip locks to use for a family vacation a
girl guide or Scout weekend or even just
a sleepover pack your child's clothes
buy outfits in a ziplock it will allow
you to see how many changes of clothes
they have and also save you the
and depending on the kid the time it
takes to pick out clothes you can even
have them help you put their outfits
together for the trip if they want to
help then fold them all up and shove
them into that ziplock number two no
longer we all have to learn how to use a
toilet at some point and it normally is
a messy
not to mention smelly experience we
can't make the snow go away yet but we
can make your potty training device a
little cleaner when your little guy or
gal needs to go number two throw down a
coffee filter in the bottom of the
training pot the filter will hold the
amazing present your child has made and
when they're done you can just grab the
edges of the coffee filter and pop it
out nice and easy and mess-free tapes
off speakers the noises your kids toys
make are cute for a while they can
definitely be the cause of an explosion
when the irritation of noises is no
longer tolerable of course we all try
our best but there's a limit on mom and
dad's ears can take so those chaotic
toys are too much after a long day at
work or even a long day at home grab
some good old scotch tape and place a
few strands over the speakers on the
toys this will cut the noise down
significantly while still allowing your
child to play faucet extender standing
on your tippy toes to reach the sink
will definitely make it a challenge to
wash your hand let alone see what you're
doing by making the faucet longer those
smaller arms can get all the water they
need to set up the bubbles some stores
sell actual items that can clip on to
the sink but why buy something when you
can do it yourself for free hence also
saves you time by not going to the store
take an old lotion bottle and cut off
both ends one into smaller hole to go
over your faucet the other bigger for
the water to flow out fasten it over the
faucet and the water will be directed
further out to reach the kids hands
melting treat savor children with melted
ice cream running down their hands is a
common summer picture one that we're
going to help you avoid you can use this
trick for store-bought popsicles and ice
cream on a stick but also for homemade
pops place a cupcake holder both
affordable and easy to take along on
trips to the car under the popsicle plug
the hole through the middle of the
bottom of the cupcake liner and push it
up the stick until it hits the bottom of
the ice cream the Sun melts all frozen
cheese but now no more sticky fingers
phone number four
depending on your child's age they may
have a cellphone even if just for their
safety if they don't you may worry about
them on school outings or we may walk
home from school with cow either way you
can make them feel calmer by helping
them make a bracelet with their phone
number on it this will also help them
not only memorize their number if they
haven't already but also let anyone help
them out if needed by calling you of
course this is worst case scenario but
better safe than sorry
a game of chores chores are never fun
for kids because they are called chores
now this one isn't a revolutionary idea
but it sure is a valuable one making
chores into a game always makes your
kids more willing to help out tape an
area on the floor where they can sweep
all the dirt into or have a race to see
who can pick up the most toys maybe even
count steps out to the garbage there are
endless ways to do this so get creative
and get those little dudes to help you
with the family household duties laundry
basket bath that time can be the best
time of day for your child sitting in
the warm water splashing around with mr.
ducky but for the little ones who can't
walk yet or it's too slippery to stand
toys can easily float out of reach keep
them all closed by simply placing the
laundry basket into the bathtub and
putting your toddler inside it not only
will it be something for them to hold on
to but it will also keep all their
favorite toys close to them while they
get clean and while they play you can
secretly scrub that dirt behind their
ears padlocks 2 plugs as parents you
worry and rightfully so because there
are dangers and hazards everywhere to
take some of the worries off your mind
thanks tiny padlocks that you can buy at
most any corner or drugstore and lock
them around the hole in the electrical
device Plus this will keep your curious
adventurous child from accidentally
plugging in appliances that could end up
hurting them as for the electrical
sockets in the wall you can buy covers
for those as well and this is a genius
hack to complement it no card more
fights this isn't only going to stop
your kids from arguments and fights but
it will also put a smile on your face
cut pieces of cardboard to pick between
your kids in the car every time you
check in the rearview mirror they will
sectioned off like they're in a package
how could that not make you smile
hopefully the kid spikes don't get so
serious these cardboard barriers are
needed but for long car rides or
vacations this could be your sanity
Savior it can also be used as a
distraction on those long trips give
them a couple of markers and let them go
wild on the cardboard magnet cups adults
and children alike can sometimes use
more cups than needed each time we get a
drink we grab another glass you get it
maybe kids do it a little more often but
to help them keep the same glass we have
a little trick blue magnets onto the
back of their favorite plastic cup and
stick it to the water cooler or the
fridge at a height they can reach
then every time they want to drink they
know where their glass will be this will
also give them more responsibility and
getting their cup and their own beverage
even if they need help they'll have the
first step down all on their own way to
empower your kid fitted sheet for
outdoors the outdoors can make your baby
or toddler feel vulnerable whether it be
the backyard or the beach we got a hack
for you everyone has one of these in
their home it is a fitted bed sheet take
one to the beach and use it as a
protector from the sand keep it held
open with your bags and baskets then
place your baby inside this will keep
the sand from blowing into their face
using the same sheet you can place it on
top of your baby's crib outside to keep
the mosquitoes and the Sun off they're
delicately soft skin just make sure the
crib has mesh around the sides so they
don't overheat these super Iser
whether kids are running jumping or
hiding falling at some point always
seems to be the results the boundless
energy your tyke has sometimes gets
beaten by the Polish spores to prevent
slips and falls use a hot glue gun to
make the bottom of their shoe slip proof
make a couple lines across the front of
the heels then let it dry for at least a
day when the hot glue hardens it
basically turns into rubber making an
instant drip on the bottom of their
shoes now they can have the shoes they
want with a grip they may not have right
or left foot shoes can be difficult at
first not only learning how to tie laces
but also which foot goes where to make
their lives easy cut a fun large sticker
in half and place one half on
to the inside of each foot in the heel
area the heel area will allow the
sticker to stay as their foot will press
directly down on to it as they walk by
having the sticker there when the shoes
are on the right side the sticker will
be whole this will then clearly indicate
which foot goes where color
time-management being young is fun and
easy except when you have dreaded things
to do like homework chores and getting
ready for bed you know the usual stuff
so how about making it into a fun color
coded game with paint chips trips you
can pick up a mini paint chip strips as
you need I have two local hardware store
and let your kids choose the ones they
like use as many as you need to make
their days seem fun and easy while still
getting stuff done time management and
fun who thought those two opposites
could ever go together see the cries
them for accident-prone kids little guys
and gals are prone to boo-boos it's just
a fact kids get hurt and that's bad but
there are some kids that seem to end up
with more bumps and bruises than most if
that's your little mini of you then
Sheela Kaizen is the magical essential
oil that you need it's an anti
inflammatory nature oil derived from a
plant in the sunflower family that
contains properties which heal our skin
it's used for multiple reasons from
skincare to invigorating your work by
smelling it it is also known as the
everlasting flower due to its many uses
sounds like something everyone should
stock up on in their medicine cabinets
hide candy in frozen veg bags now this
hack is for you you do everything for
your kids and you'll be able to do even
more for them if you take care of
yourself and how exactly by storing
candy in an empty frozen vegetable bag
that's right you got your own secret
stash and it ain't stealing the kids
Halloween candy this is for you when
you've had enough and a mini Mars bar or
M&Ms or all you need to keep on keepin
on
let's be honest that's the last place
your kids are going to search for tree
recycle crib in two kicks play desk
reduce reuse and recycle right as the 3
R's can save loads of money around the
house with a little creativity when your
baby grows up into a toddler why not
turn that old crib into a fun craft area
or a desk by taking out one of the sides
of slates you can push little chairs up
for their bums to
one two and get creative the slates
around the desk can be used to hang
their crafts and pictures it's a fun way
for them to have a desk and also have
that familiarity with it now there
doesn't have to be any sad tears about
throwing out the crib you shall not pass
toilet paper is really fun around the
house not only use for going number one
and number two but also for crafts and
mummy costumes in an attempt to save the
environment as well as your toilet from
getting clogged make a fun you shall not
pass sign that signals to your kid how
much toilet paper to use this will save
you money save your kid from unwinding
the whole roll and do your part
intervene Green the sign is so fun to
look at we think it's the best way to
use a Lord of the Rings reference you'll
be the coolest parents around which half
do you think will be most useful do you
know any others let us know in the
comments below thanks for watching
xx Dinah's parenting hacks and see you
next time
[Music]